Chapeau, lunettes de soleil, parasol,
je suis prêt pour un bon bain de soleil.
Ah, j'allais oublier la crème solaire,
même à l'ombre, elle est utile.
Ça nous est toutes et tous arrivé
un jour ou l'autre, un coup de soleil.
Ça fait mal et c'est pas très bon pour notre santé.
Aujourd'hui, je vous explique pourquoi
on attrape un coup de soleil.
Comment s'en protéger ?
À quoi correspondent les chiffres
sur les flacons de crèmes solaire ?
Et, pourquoi nous ne sommes pas tous
aussi sensibles au Soleil ?
Le Soleil,
émet de la lumière, de la lumière visible,
les fameuses couleurs de l'arc en ciel,
mais pas seulement.
Une partie de son rayonnement échappe
à notre regard.
Nos yeux n'y sont pas sensibles.
Heureusement,
une grande partie d'entre eux
est arrêtée par la couche d'ozone,
mais pas les UVA et B.
Ce sont eux
qui peuvent faire du tort à notre peau.
Voici une maquette représentant la peau
en coupe avec ses 3 couches : l'hypoderme,
le derme et au-dessus, l'épiderme.
Oui, je sais, ça chatouille.
Les UVB pénètrent dans la couche
superficielle de la peau, l'épiderme,
jusqu'à la couche
basale située à l'interface du derme-épiderme,
où se trouvent
les cellules souches de la peau.
C'est cette couche qui, en se régénérant,
permet à la peau
de se renouveler en permanence.
Le problème, c'est que les UVB pénètrent
au cœur des cellules et atteignent l'ADN
contenu dans leur noyau.
Or, une fois l'ADN touché, les cellules
ne fonctionnent plus correctement.
Elles peuvent même dégénérer.
Notre organisme choisit
alors de s'en débarrasser.
À ce moment-là,
l'afflux sanguin augmente pour que
les globules blancs fassent le ménage.
Les vaisseaux s'élargissent,
c'est la réaction inflammatoire.
Et, c'est bien parce que les vaisseaux
se dilatent, pour laisser passer
davantage de sang, que la peau rougit
et que l'on éprouve une sensation
de chaleur et de douleur.
Ah c'est sûr, je ne mets plus le nez dehors !
Heureusement, ça ne se passe pas tout le temps comme ça,
uniquement lorsque l'on s'expose
sans prendre garde.
Il est hors de question de se passer
complètement de soleil,
notre organisme a besoin de lumière.
Elle régule notre horloge biologique,
notre humeur,
elle active la production de vitamine
D, celle que l'on surnomme
la vitamine du Soleil.
Nos os en ont besoin pour fixer le calcium
et elle stimule aussi
notre système immunitaire.
Nous devons donc apprendre à vivre
avec le Soleil.
Heureusement, notre peau dispose
de systèmes de défenses naturelles
contre les UVB.
La couche cornée d'abord,
une couverture constituée
de cellules de peaux mortes
qui agit comme un film protecteur.
Elle renvoie une partie des UVB.
Plus on s'expose au Soleil,
plus cette couche s'épaissit.
Et ce n'est pas tout, plus en profondeur,
l'ADN au niveau de chaque cellule est protégé par des pigments : la mélanine.
La peau en contient plus ou moins
selon qu'elle est claire ou foncée.
La mélanine agit comme un bouclier
en absorbant les UVB.
Elle est produite par des cellules
spécialisées, les mélanocytes.
Plus il y a de soleil, plus
les mélanocytes produisent de mélanine.
Il faut 48h pour que le processus se mette en place.
C'est pourquoi il est recommandé de s'exposer
au Soleil graduellement quand on part
en vacances.
Quelques minutes au départ,
puis un peu plus chaque jour,
et peu à peu, la peau prend des couleurs.
En effet, quand une cellule de peau meurt,
elle est poussée vers la surface
en transportant la mélanine qu'elle contient.
Plus on s'expose au soleil,
plus les cellules
qui s'empilent dans l'épiderme
contiennent donc de la mélanine
et plus on est bronzé.
Ceci explique aussi qu'une fois
l'été passé, le bronzage disparaît.
Les cellules qui contiennent beaucoup
de mélanine, comme toutes les cellules,
arrivent à la surface de l'épiderme
et elles disparaissent.
La peau desquame, comme on dit.
Comme il y a moins de soleil,
elles sont petit à petit remplacées
par des cellules
qui contiennent moins de mélanine.
Mais alors,
s'il faut s'exposer pour
produire de la mélanine et que la mélanine
nous protège du Soleil,
à quoi ça sert
de se badigeonner de crème ?
Tu ne pouvais pas me le dire plus tôt ?
Parce que la mélanine ne fait pas tout.
D'abord parce qu'en fonction
de notre pigmentation,
nous en produisons plus ou moins.
Moi, par exemple, qui ai la peau claire
j'en produit peu, moins que Teddy Riner
ou Will Smith.
Donc, le bouclier
n'a pas toujours la même efficacité.
Du coup, il y en a
qui peuvent se passer de crème solaire ?
Pas du tout car si la mélanine protège
assez efficacement contre les UVB,
elle laisse passer
un autre type d'ultraviolet : les UVA.
Souvenez-vous, eux aussi arrivent
jusqu'à nous.
Ceci pénètre encore plus profondément
au niveau de
la deuxième couche de la peau, le derme.
Ils s'attaquent à sa structure
et à long terme,
ce sont les principaux responsables
du vieillissement cutané
et du développement
des cancers de la peau.
Donc, peu importe la pigmentation,
il faut se protéger du Soleil.
Le peuple Touareg l'a bien compris.
Malgré les fortes chaleurs du désert,
ils se couvrent entièrement de tissus
à la maille serrée
pour ne pas laisser passer les UV.
En Égypte antique,
on trouve aussi des papyrus
qui font déjà mention de produits destinés
à la protection solaire.
Les crèmes solaires
que nous utilisons aujourd'hui
ont vu le jour au début du XXᵉ siècle
au Japon, aux États-Unis puis en France,
avec ce que l'on appelait l'ambre solaire.
Leur utilisation a vraiment explosé
avec les premiers congés payés en 1936,
les premières vacances au bord de la mer.
Alors, vous l'avez deviné,
les crèmes solaires sont conçues
pour empêcher les rayons ultraviolets
de pénétrer dans la peau.
Pour cela, elles contiennent différents
types de filtres
qui absorbent
ou repoussent le rayonnement solaire.
Mais du coup,
20, 30, 50, qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
C'est l'indice SPF : Sunburn Protection Factor
le facteur de protection solaire.
Il indique la capacité du produit à
retarder l'apparition d'un coup de soleil.
Pour le calculer,
on expose une petite surface
de peau d'un courageux volontaire
à un rayonnement ultraviolet.
Une partie de cette surface
est recouverte de crème, l'autre non.
Et on mesure le temps qui s'écoule
jusqu'au moment
où la peau commence à rougir.
Si le coup de soleil apparaît
au bout de 2 minutes sur la peau nue,
alors qu'il n'apparaît qu'au
bout d'1 heure sur la surface protégée,
l'indice de protection est de 30.
Car la durée d'exposition avant l'apparition
du coup de soleil a été multipliée par 30.
Un indice de protection de 50 signifie
que le facteur de retardement
a été multiplié par 50.
Et 50+, ça veut dire quoi ?
C'est ce qui est mentionné
lorsque l'indice de protection
est supérieur à 60.
2 minutes, par exemple, pour que la peau rougisse en l'absence de protection,
120 minutes,
2h ou plus avec la protection.
Pour autant, aucun produit
ne peut permettre une protection totale.
C'est pour cette raison qu'en Europe,
la mention "écran total"
a disparu des emballages depuis 2006.
50, ça devrait le faire !
Bon, il faut quand même être très vigilant
avec les crèmes.
Les tests sont réalisés
dans des conditions de laboratoire.
Ils ne prennent pas en compte
tous les aspects de la vie quotidienne :
une mauvaise application,
la transpiration, le frottement
des vêtements ou du sable sur la peau,
la baignade.
Bref, on estime que la protection
est au moins réduite
de moitié par rapport
aux tests réalisés en laboratoire.
Du coup,
quand vous lisez 30, pensez plutôt 15.
C'est pour cette raison
qu'il est fortement conseillé
de renouveler l'application de la crème
au moins toutes les 2h
et après chaque baignade.
Bien reçu cette fois,
j'ai mis la dose.
Pour ta peau, c'est très bien.
Pour l'environnement,
en revanche, c'est pas drôle du tout.
Chaque année, près de 25000 tonnes
de crème solaire
se diluent dans les mers et les océans,
2 fois et demi
le poids de la tour Eiffel.
Or, certains composés chimiques
contenus à l'intérieur
peuvent perturber la faune marine,
en particulier les coraux.
Ils détruisent les larves du corail,
perturbent leur reproduction
et provoquent leur blanchissement.
Pour lutter contre cette pollution, certains pays, comme la Thaïlande, Hawaï
ou l'archipel de Palaos dans le Pacifique,
ont purement et simplement interdit
les crèmes solaires les plus toxiques.
À savoir celles qui contiennent
de l'oxybenzone, de l'octocrylène
et des parabènes.
Ces composés sont présents
dans la plupart des crèmes
vendues par les grandes marques.
Selon plusieurs associations écologistes
la crème 100% biodégradable
et sans impact
sur l'environnement, n'existe
pas encore.
En fait,
pour se protéger la peau, des risques
de coups de soleil et de cancers cutanés
sans polluer l'environnement,
eh bien, il faut se couvrir
avec des vêtements légers
même pour la baignade.
Comme ça ?
Ça te va très bien !
De cette manière, on réduit
les parties du corps à protéger avec de
la crème qui se limite au visage, aux
oreilles, aux avant-bras et aux jambes.
Enfin, il est préférable de ne pas
s'exposer au soleil entre 10h et 16h.
Et n'oubliez pas non plus
le chapeau
et les lunettes de soleil.
Voilà, je suis sûr que maintenant
vous en connaissez
un rayon sur les coups de soleil.
Je vous souhaite une excellente semaine
et à dimanche prochain.
Woah, il n'y a pas un pet' de nuage.